la technologie bitcoin au service de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
voilà un défi n'est ce pas de la roue à
internet en passant par l'imprimerie les
inventions les plus remarquables de
l'histoire humaine sont celles qui ont
permis de résoudre des enjeux de
civilisation qu'elle avait a priori pas
envisagé
c'est ainsi que du statut d' inventions
elle accède à celui de révolution
la technologie bitcoin n'a pas été créé
pour résoudre la crise que logique à
laquelle nous faisons face
mais elles portent certainement cet
espoir est elle en a le pouvoir
c'est avec internet une des inventions
révolution les plus profondes de notre
temps et sans doute la plus à même de
relever le plus grand défi que l'homme
ne s'est jamais créés contre lui-même
le changement climatique je sens un peu
de scepticisme dans la salle vous vous
dites foutaise
de ce que j'en sais le bitcoin est
plutôt un truc très énergivore une
pseudo monnaie qui ne sert à rien et qui
ne reposent sur rien alors commençons si
vous le voulez par désamorcer levé ce
malentendu
en décortiquant le mot bitcoin vite d'un
côté comme de l'autre qui signifie comme
vous le savez en anglais pièces de
monnaie et pas commencer à se poser à la
fois une question très simple mais
complexe qu'est ce que la monnaie la
monnaie c'est comme vous le savez
d'abord une valeur des changes qui vous
permet d'acheter ou de vendre un bien
sans passer par la case du troc mais
c'est plus que cela c'est un instrument
dans lequel vous avez confiance parce
qu'il repose sur des institutions dans
lesquelles vous avez confiance et c'est
grâce à cette confiance que vous lui
accordez que la monnaie peut structurer
tous nos échanges
une grande partie des relations humaines
c'est la colonne vertébrale de notre
économie et à ce titre au delà de sa
valeur des changes la monnaie une valeur
institutionnelle puisque sous une forme
ou sous une autre
elle dépasse les frontières et
traversent le temps qu'est ce que le bit
maintenant contraction en anglais deux
unités d'information binaire dont la
valeur est soit 0 soit 1,7 à partir de
ces deux chiffres ces deux bits que l'on
encode les valeurs logique de toutes les
applications numériques qui gère le
monde et notre quotidien
le beat est le plus petit dénominateur
commun du monde digital
c'est en quelque sorte sa particule
élémentaire sont centime ni aucune
différence fondamentale entre un
paiement cas par carte bleue
le programme de gestion d'une centrale
nucléaire ou la musique que vous écoutez
sur votre portable
le beat est partout c'est la colonne
vertébrale du monde digital et de
l'économie numérique
vous avez appris lui faire confiance
comme la monnaie comme la monnaie vous
ne pouvez sans doute plus vous en passer
il a donc acquis une valeur
institutionnelle comme la monnaie sous
une forme ou sous une autre
il peut dépasser les frontières
géographiques et physique et traversent
le temps vous comprenez maintenant
l'intérêt qu'il y avait de réunir la
monnaie et le bit sous une même
technologie
le bitcoin c'est la première forme de
crypto monnaie ça ne repose pas sur rien
c'est de l'argent liquide sur internet
dont la valeur institutionnelle repose
sur l'émergence de la civilisation
digitale
ce n'est pas rien derrière le bitcoin et
les crypto monnaie il ya la technologie
qu'on appelle les blocs chaîne c'est
cette technologie qui va nous permettre
de relever le défi climatique
parlons de la blocs chaînes comme d'un
grand livre de contes sur lequel on peut
enregistrer des contrats à contre à une
transaction sans que personne ne puisse
remettre en cause son authenticité
ce livre de contes et de fait le
meilleur coffre fort que l'on n'est
jamais fabriqué à ce jour dans
l'histoire humaine inaltérable un
falsifiable inviolable son contenu le
réplique dans le new comme le maillon
d'une chaîne sur un grand nombre de
serveurs informatiques de façon à ce que
chacun puisse le vérifier
sans jamais pouvoir s'approprier ce qui
ne lui appartient pas la clé de son
fonctionnement
c'est le maintien d'un consensus par
lequel tous ceux qui d'un bout à l'autre
de la chaîne ont un intérêt dans le
coffre ont également intérêt à ce qu'ils
ne soient jamais violé c'est donc un
système de confiance à part entière fort
de cette confiance là blocs shell cette
technologie look shell peut revendiquer
une valeur institutionnelle et donc se
substituer la défaillance ou à l'absence
d'institutions par exemple pour la
reconnaissance de la propriété foncière
dans les pays qui n'ont pas de cadastre
pour l'assurance d'un vote sans fond
dans les états qui prétendent à la
démocratie tout la reconnaissance de
l'identité des migrants dans leur pays
d'origine le ressorte leur ont supprimé
leurs cartes d'identité ou leurs
passeports ou nous mêmes plus
d'administration pour en délivrer la
valeur institutionnelle de cette
technologie porte la promesse de kde
usage haute valeur ajoutée sociale
ce sera aussi le garant de la protection
de vos données personnelles dans le
futur elle porte aussi la promesse d'une
nouvelle gouvernance fondée sur les
principes émergents de notre société
principe de décentralisation principe de
collaboration du consensus de
transparence d'intégrité
ça fait beaucoup mais ce sont les
propriétés de la blocs sonné et c'est
bien de ces principes dont on a
aujourd'hui besoin
la dynamique planétaire qui vous l'avez
compris peine à se mettre en place pour
concrétiser les engagements de l'accord
de paris sur le climat résoudre le
problème du changement climatique
consiste en gros à compter les émissions
de co2 qui partent dans l'atmosphère et
faire en sorte d'en réduire le volume de
façon à limiter le réchauffement moyen
de la terre à 2 degrés si possible à 1,5
degré
la principale difficulté dans cette
affaire c'est de mettre tous les pays du
monde d'accord sur le principe de
réduction mais aussi sur une clé de
répartition de l'effort qui peut émettre
du co2 et combien la bonne nouvelle
c'est que 195 pays ont fini par se
mettre d'accord en signant ratifiant
même comme vous le savez l'accord de
paris sur le climat signé en décembre
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'ils ont
oublié de dire combien
ou plus exactement chacun dans cet
accord peut dire le combien qui lui
convient ce qui revient à peu près au
même et vous le comprenez ce qui n'aide
pas à gérer la clé de répartition et
sesat oublie que la blocs shell va
pouvoir nous permettre de combler avec
son livre de contes son coffre fort son
mécanisme d'intégrité et de consensus
mais aussi sa capacité à générer des
crypto monnaie c'est dans cet objectif
que nous avons créé clarinette chaîne
une initiative de recherche appliquée
visant à démontrer l'aptitude de la
technologie blocs chaîne à faciliter et
à renforcer les ambitions de l'accord de
paris nous avons commencé par répliquer
le coffre fort français des émissions de
co2 générées sur le territoire national
est tenu par la caisse des dépôts
l'idée n'est pas de remplacer la caisse
de dépôt par une blocs chaîne
l'idée est d'offrir et de construire un
coffre fort du carbone pour le tous les
pays qui n'ont ni caisse des dépôts sont
nombreux ni système institutionnel
suffisamment fort et fiable pour
inspirer confiance sur la valeur de
leurs émissions de co2 et surtout sur la
valeur des émissions qu'ils évitent ou
qu'ils compensent par exemple en
plantant des arbres en gardant leurs
forêts intactes
l'objectif à terme est d'établir une
sorte de cadastre mondiale des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre un système
d'intégrité et de consensus tel qu'il
puisse conférer à cette klein chaîne
une valeur institutionnelle sur laquelle
on peut bâtir un système de changes mais
peut-être la colonne vertébrale d'une
économie bas carbone une clarinette
chaîne n'est effectivement pas
compatible avec le bitcoin dont le
coffre fort s'appuie sur une puissance
de calcul extrêmement énergivore et
qu'il n'est absolument pas compatible
avec la lutte contre le changement
climatique
pour vous donner une idée un beat conne
nécessite de rejeter dans l'atmosphère
près de deux tonnes de carbone ce qui
correspond à peu près au budget carbone
annuel moyen d'un français si on veut
espérer rester dans les limites du
réchauffement de deux degrés forte
heureusement des processus des
protocoles de consensus alternative
émergent commence à exister à se
développer qui permettent d'envisager
une block chaîne climatiquement
responsable mais surtout surtout une
économie plus responsables avec la blocs
chaîne en effet la monnaie peut non
seulement avoir de la valeur mais aussi
des valeurs
il est désormais possible de concevoir
des cryptes monnaie qui soit socialement
désirable en les programmant de façon à
ce que leurs valeurs financières soient
générés sur la base de valeurs éthiques
une crypte monnaies locales acclamée de
shell permet de monétiser des émissions
de co2 de faire en sorte que ceux qui
polluent puissent en acheter à ceux qui
sont vertueux c'est le principe des
crédits carbone mais on peut aller plus
loin il est possible d'encoder dans l'
usage de ses cryptes monnaie une formule
selon laquelle l'impact négatif sur le
climat de vos dépenses on affecterait la
valeur al'inverse vos dépenses
plus vertueuse voire carrément l'absence
de dépenses seraient récompensés par un
mécanisme d'incitation en développant ce
principe on peut imaginer un usage de
l'argent qui colle non seulement au
moyen de ceux qui le détiennent mais
aussi à leur valeur allez allons encore
un peu plus loin
l' avantage d'une crypte monnaie par
rapport à de l'argent liquide un
chéquier même une carte bleue ce qui
peut embarquer de l'intelligence
artificielle que l'on peut relier non
seulement aux objets connectés à travers
ce qu'on appelle l'internet des objets
mais aussi agir sur eux
imaginez un crypto monnaie virtuelle
interconnecté intelligent capable
d'analyser les données de son
environnement et de prendre des
décisions de façon autonome
un algorithme intelligent bien sûr
estime évalue la valeur sociale
environnementale de vos dépenses et le
cas échéant il substitue un produit ou
un service équivalent mais qui a une
meilleure empreinte carbone il pourrait
pendant que vous dormez arbitré deux
façons vertueuse tous vos achats sur
l'internet
pour vos courses de la semaine pour
alors vraiment dire que l'argent ne dort
jamais et comme il n'aime pas dormir que
vous pouvez faire confiance à nos
gouvernements pour faire en sorte qu'ils
ne dorment jamais il est vraisemblable
que d'ici 2035 l'euro le dollar et
toutes les devises se convertissent
d'abord partiellement puis totalement en
crypto monnaie
plus d'une dizaine de pays singapour
[Musique]
l'équateur la chine bientôt la suède ont
déjà doublé leurs devises nationales
d'une crypte aux monnaies l'argent tel
que vous le connaissez aujourd'hui ne
sera bientôt plus que de l'histoire
ancienne
allez allons encore un petit peu plus
loin il sera bientôt possible de
programmer toutes ses cryptes monnaie de
façon à aligner la valeur globale des
échanges sur les ressources disponibles
de notre planète
un peu comme l'heure de tous les
appareils électroniques est aligné sur
les horloges atomiques
on pourra faire en sorte que les
transactions économiques global ne
dépasse jamais la capacité de la terre
en fournir la matière première
car c'est une des tragédies de notre
société nous consommons chaque année
près de deux fois la capacité de la
terre à fournir les ressources dont nous
avons besoin les talons monétaire ne
sera plus l'or comme avant la fin des
accords de bretton woods mais le climat
la biodiversité la qualité de l'air et
tout ce qu'on appelle les fonctions
essentielles de nos écosystèmes dans un
tel système
le sort du capital financier se rallier
au capital naturel
il y sera même arrimer pour alors
vraiment parler de sagesse monétaire
la dématérialisation n'empêche pas la
relation avec la matière au contraire
elle peut l'enrichir
tout est question de schéma mental et de
se donner les moyens de se représenter
nos plus les choses comme elles sont
mais comme elle pourrait être y aller
allons jusqu'au bout du raisonnement le
processus de création monétaire lui même
peut être inversée faire en sorte que ce
soit plus les banques centrales qui
décide de façon arbitraire et seule la
quantité de monnaie nécessaire à une
économie à notre économie ni les banques
à travers les crédits qu'elles octroient
quand elles veulent bien le faire mais
faire en sorte que ce soit vos choix
économiques vos transactions les plus
importantes vos dépenses quotidiennes
dès lors qu'elles sont conformes ou
qu'elle représente une valeur ajoutée
sociale environnementale qui produisent
non pas une monnaie de singe mais une
monnaie de singe merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]